over the last two decades the US has
seen many cases of police brutality
involving the black community do you
still hold hope that the situation in
the u.s. can't improve it can only
improve with fundamental change you
cannot have a society that is unjust in
so many different ways have a just law
enforcement system we have police
brutality we have mass incarceration and
they're all tied together this this man
George Floyd was being arrested for he
was accused of having a phony $20 bill
but people are arrested for that and
even less every day in this country and
they're fed into this mass incarceration
system more than two million people the
US has more people in prison than any
other country in the world and and then
the u.s. is the world's worst abuser of
human rights so we have to have a
fundamental change that says that
aggression abroad and at home and you
cannot have justice at home and
injustice abroad they are tied together
you must have cut the military budget
send close these 800 military bases
around the world and also empty the
prison's the prison population could
easily be cut in half so you can't have
inequality kleptocracy mass
incarceration aggression abroad and have
a just police system that is not going
to happen
well shamefully in many cases this
situation with George Floyd has turned
political and there have been some
severe dog whistles being blown if you
will what about your reaction to
President Trump in his response to the
killing of George Floyd has it been
adequate has it been lacking what are
your thoughts well it has been lacking
but he's like his predecessor this this
happened and I think it was 2015 in
Baltimore man
Freddie gray was killed by the police
and there was a an upper a popular
uprising a rebellion and President Obama
called the protesters thugs so Donald
Trump we see once again is not the
outlier we are told that he is his
behavior is in keeping with that of his
predecessors and that's one of the
fundamental changes of the Prentis the
presidency so the presidents are not
going to be better than the system that
we have they may speak more softly like
Obama they may be blustery like the bull
in the china shop with no manners like
Trump but in the end they all defend
this system which kills people in so
many ways
three people every day a thousand people
are killed by the police every year most
often not on camera but we had people
dying of kovat 19 because of our
inadequate health care system people
dying because they have suffered with
low-wage work there all sorts of things
that shorten people's lives in this
country so I would urge people who are
so moved and I am glad that people were
so outraged at the witnessing this man's
murder but there is a much bigger
picture that has to be attacked if we
want to end the scourge of police
brutality going to this incident
specifically the officer who knelt on
George Floyd has been charged with
third-degree murder I'm gonna ask you to
go down the rabbit hole with me just a
little bit if you don't mind
is there any chance he'll be sentenced
it's possible it generally does not
happen but I think we have to thank the
protesters you know everybody says they
want peaceful protest but I am convinced
unless the night before he was finally
arrested protesters burned down a police
precinct in Minneapolis and I am
convinced that it is that kind of action
which drove them to arrest him there
trying to mollify the public but if the
public does not show its anger there is
no action taken so we have to thank the
protesters we have to thank the people
who burned that precinct we have to
thank the people who protested outside
the home of the prosecutor who the day
before indicated that he was not ready
to make an arrest all of these pressures
caused the arrests to take place and
that pressure must be sustained and if
it is if they are afraid of losing
control then it's possible he can be
convicted but I think it depends on the
people and what the people do let's talk
about the people and those protesters a
little bit more the Minnesota governor
has said that violence is no longer just
about George Floyd's death do you think
the protests are being downplayed by the
politicians or getting lost as the
rioting grows in intensity or are they
inextricably linked oh the politicians
are trying to downplay and dismiss but
we should not be fooled
these are polity and by the way these
protests have broken out across the
country all over the United States the
anger not only about this man but but
about the conditions that people live in
that with this kovat 19 pandemic people
out of work and we had an economy who's
not as strong as Americans are led to
believe people are suffering and so in
order they but they want to make sure
people don't protest anything they don't
want people to protest against mr.
Floyd's killing or anything in this
country so of course they're going to
downplay it but I think it's important
also to say that spontaneous reactions
are not good enough we need organizing
sustained organizing too so that we
don't react every time there's a new
outrage that we see on video and group I
am affiliated with black Alliance for
peace our campaign no compromise no
retreat we are demanding that
politicians cut the military budget that
they
militarizing the police that they
investigate all cases of lethal force in
this country and that is why we are
organizing so that people can sustain
this pressure and really make change so
that when there is that we we are not
just reacting to the most outrageous see
outrageous thing that someone manages to
video now you've outlined a good path to
getting the protesters off the streets
what about the vicious cycle that
continues
will there be consequences for the
looters and the arsonists and how will
that play out I I don't know how that's
gonna plan I'm not worried about the
consequences for people who protested
I'm gonna call it a rebellion of people
may say rioting looting I don't really
care I'm not concerned about the
consequences for them I'm concerned
about the consequences for the police
and for this system that is so corrupt
that is why they're trying to get people
off the streets that is why they're
telling people not to protest anymore
because they know that the fact that
people rise up like this means they want
to be organized they want to know what
to do about their lives and about this
country and the goal of the politicians
is to make people quiet again and to
make people passive again so we should
not listen to them when they say don't
protest when they say go back home as I
said before the this first step of
charging this officer would never have
happened without this public protest and
we should remember that whenever these
politicians and these other so-called
leaders tell people to stay all right
very interesting to hear your thoughts
and thank you for your insight
Margaret Kimberly a columnist for the
black agenda report website thanks for
being with us here on arts international
you